Charles by the grace of God king of the
Franks and lombards and patrician of the
Romans to the revered man his dearest
brother offer king of the mercy ins
sends greetings of present prosperity
and eternal blessedness in Christ
[Music]
between royal dignities and exalted
personages of the world the keeping of
the laws of friendship joined in the
unity of peace and the Concord of holy
love with the deepest affection of heart
is want to be of profit to many and if
we are commanded by our Lord's precept
to untie the knots of MDT how much more
ought we to take care to secure the
links of love hence most beloved brother
mindful of the ancient pact between us
we have sent these letters to your
reverence that the treaty established in
the route of faith may flourish in the
fruit of love having perused your
brotherly letters which have at diverse
times been brought to us by the hands of
your messengers and endeavoring to reply
adequately to these several suggestions
of your authority we first give thanks
to the Almighty God for the sincerity of
the Catholic faith which we found
laudably set down in your pages
recognizing you to not only be a most
strong protector of your earthly country
but also a most devout defender of the
holy faith concerning pilgrims who for
the love of God and the salvation of
their souls desire to reach the
thresholds of the Blessed apostles as we
granted formally they may go in peace
free from all molestation bearing with
them the necessities for their journey
but we have discovered that certain
persons fraudulently mingle with them
for the sake of commerce seeking gain
not serving religion if such are found
among them they are to pay the
established toll at the proper places
the others
may go in peace immune from toll you
have written to us also about merchants
and by our mandate we allow that they
shall have protection and support in our
kingdom lawfully according to the
ancient custom of trading and if in any
place they are afflicted by wrongful
oppression they may appeal to us or to
our judges and we will then order true
justice to be done similarly our men if
they suffer any injustice in your
Dominion are to appeal to the judgment
of your equity lest any disturbance
should arise anywhere between our men
regarding the priests odd bird who
desires on his return from Rome to live
abroad for the love of God as he often
says and did not come to accuse you I
inform you dear brother that we have
sent him to Rome with the other ex Iles
who in fear of death have taken refuge
under the wings of our protection so
that in the presence of the apostolic
Lord and your Archbishop since as your
letters have informed us they had bound
themselves by a vow their cause may be
heard and judged that equitable judgment
may be effective where pious
intercession failed what could be safer
for us than that the opinion of the
apostolic authority should determine a
case in which the views of others
disagree
as for the black stones which your
reverence beg to be sent to you let a
messenger come and consider what kind
you have in mind and we will willingly
order them to be given wherever they are
to be found and will help with their
transport but as you have intimated your
wishes concerning the length of the
stones so our people make a demand about
the size of the cloaks that you may
order them to be such as used to come to
us in former times
moreover we make known to your love that
we have sent a gift from our Dalma ticks
and poles to the various episodes of
your kingdom and of ethelred's in arms
for the apostolic lord Hadrian our
Father and your friend beseeching you to
ordered diligent intercession for his
soul not having any doubt that his
blessed soul is at rest but to show our
trust and love towards a friend most
dear to us also the Blessed Augustine
has taught that intercessions of
ecclesiastical piety ought to be made
for all asserting that to intercede for
a good man profits him who does it also
from the treasure of earthly riches
which the Lord Jesus Christ has granted
us with freely bestowed kindness we have
sent something to each of the
metropolitan cities also to your love
for joy and Thanksgiving to Almighty God
we have sent a belt and a Hunnish sword
and two silk poles
to the end that everywhere among
Christian people the divine clemency may
be preached and the name of our Lord
Jesus Christ be glorified in eternity we
pray that you cause assiduous
into secessions to be made for us and
for our faithful subjects nay more for
all Christian people that the most
merciful goodness of the heavenly King
may day in to protect exalt and extend
the kingdom of the Holy Church
may Almighty God Dane to preserve in
long-lasting prosperity the excellence
of your dignity unimpaired for the
protection of his Holy Church
most longed for brother
you